l'ancien président de la République
Monsieur Giscard d'estain a pris le
temps d'écrire un livre assurez-vous je
ne me suis pas trompé de rubrique ce
n'est pas un programme politique mais un
roman Le Passage roman d'amour donc
l'histoire d'une liaison entre un
notaire chasseur un peu âgé et une jeune
femme blonde rencontre sur le bord d'une
route sa peau est tiède sous la laine et
extraordinairement douce presque fragile
Nathalie réagit par un frémissement
défensif à l'envahissement de mes lèvres
mais sans chercher à protéger son épaule
que je vois ce couvrir d'un granulé
soyeux et nous nous sommes et nous nous
sommes noyés ensemble longuement enlacé
dans la sensualité de la nuit